you wrote for a little while in CERN
alive right I did I wrote for a year a
year a year like I well that's if only
they did it that nicely you know it's
funny cuz when I years in another
lifetime rode for star net live the
thing I remembered right away was just
how starstruck I got at the huge
celebrities that are everywhere
wandering around it's overwhelming
because you're just like walking down
the hall and then you're like hi Jude
Law it's so weird
who was you who was was there one
celebrity that just you went on overload
like that was that was your I lost my
mind one time and it is the most
embarrassing story ever then let's hear
it okay great I shall tell it I was
writing a sketch with Kristen Wiig who's
incredible and I was in her office and
she was at the computer typing and I was
at the couch and there was a knock on
the door and I don't remember who the
host was but it was not this person and
all of a sudden walks in Justin
Timberlake and I was obsessed with in
sync when I was 17 I mean boys like to
kiss me and I was popular but but I was
like Justin Randall Timberlake born
January 31st and 90 1981 at 6:31 a.m. I
mean I was obsessed that's sick yeah so
he comes in he's not even hosting but
that's another thing is people sometimes
just come and hang out yes he's just
like friends with everybody so I'm just
stopping by and I this was my reaction
he walks in and I went yeah and I just
stared at the ground and so now Kristen
and Justin are having a conversation
friendly banter and at the time
macGruber was coming out so she had this
poster printed out and it's her in these
tight 70s jeans and Charlie's Angels
pose and they were doing a total bit
about like girl look at that ass like
they were just like look how good you
look
and so this is when I'm like pipe in say
something say anything and so they're
just like look at that butt and I look
up and I go yeah
what a penis in that but Hail Mary pass
like what is just so first of all what's
the reaction the reaction is I believe a
polite chuckle and then a change of
subject
and I would like this put a bigger than
that but right back to the ground so
then they start talking about the
macGruber premiere and she's saying you
know just if you're in town next Friday
you should come and he was like all I'm
gonna be back in LA but thank you I'll
go see it that night though right
and so she's so sweet so she goes
Gillian if you're in town you should
come and I said oh I'm actually gonna be
back in LA and then I look at Justin
Timberlake and I go so I guess we should
go together and he his response was my
favorite he went is Kenan around to be
fair all I said in front of him was put
a penis in that butt and I asked him out
I think you handled yourself very very
well you made your intentions clear yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]